[Music]
appears to be a standard sequence
violation
ranch is growing at a stable rate and
slope
variant identified i beg your pardon
on behalf of the time variance authority
i hereby arrest you for crimes against
the sacred timeline
hands up you're coming with us
i'm sorry who's us
last chance variant
[Laughter]
it's been a very long day and i think
i've had my fill of idiots in armoured
suits telling me what to do so
if you don't mind this is actually your
last chance
now get out of my way
[Music]
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder
this is going to be my loki spoiler free
review of episodes one and two and i
gotta say
marvel with each new series that they
release on disney plus steps up their
game
one division and the falcon and the
winter soldier were both great i really
liked both of them but i
love loki and there are many different
reasons why i love this series so much
but today i'll just talk about
five and by the way that clip that you
saw in the beginning of this video that
marvel released
yesterday i just thought everybody
should know this is pretty much the
opening scene of the series there's a
tiny
bit before it but this is where it
pretty much starts so congrats you've
seen the first
let's say three minutes and as we know
we're going to be dealing with
a new slash old loki and that actually
brings me to my first reason
of why i love the show so much we get a
new
loki and yes it is still the same loki
that we know and love but he
is also different and that's really nice
because we thought in avengers infinity
war
that was it for loki and it was for that
loki but this one might have
a different fate and what i love about
what they did
with loki is we are seeing a loki that
we've never seen before
while at the same time he still has all
of those characteristics
and the traits that we love about him
but one thing you'll notice about loki
in episode 1
is that he is vulnerable we are seeing
him in
a vulnerable state one that we've never
really seen before
and it's touching and sad and real and
it's honestly quite refreshing to see we
got a little bit of it
in thor the dark world when he was
mourning over the loss of his mother
and we see him like that again but they
take it way
further so the first reason of why i
loved it so much is that we get a whole
new loki while keeping all of the
greatness that makes him
him the god of mischief the second
reason i loved it so much is because
it is actually really really funny
there's a lot of comedy involved in the
series
i mean it's loki he's the god of
mischief he's a funny guy
especially coming off of thor ragnarok
which was a great film that had a lot of
comedy to it and i'm definitely going to
talk about the actors in one of my
reasons because they are
all seriously fantastic but the
relationship
that loki and mobius owen wilson's
character have is
amazing and there's actually a lot of
different aspects to their relationship
even though they are just meeting mobius
knows who loki is he knows everything
about loki and probably knows even more
about loki than loki knows about himself
and you see that come out you see mobius
kind of
test loki to see how well he knows
himself and in that is some really great
comedy
i've said it a few times in other videos
but the chemistry between owen wilson
and tom hiddleston
is absolutely incredible and it's just a
blast to watch
but tom hiddleston also has some really
great chemistry with woonmi masaku
she is who you saw at the beginning of
this video in the loki clip she plays
hunter b15
an agent of the tva and as you can see
her and loki don't exactly get started
off on the right foot but they have a
really great back and forth that offers
a lot of comedic relief in some serious
parts of the show
now the first episode is definitely a
little bit more comedic
driven than the second episode the first
episode is very much
the setup of what is about to happen
during the loki series
during this time loki is meeting a lot
of different characters and he's finding
out who they are and who
exactly the tva is and as we all know
loki he doesn't exactly follow rules
very well
which of course always makes for great
comedy now the third reason of why i
actually loved it so much
is even though it has a lot of comedy to
it there's actually a lot of
mystery to it and not just from the main
antagonist but
everything really there are a lot of
aspects to the loki series that you
would find in a crime show
and for the first episode it kind of is
a crime episode and that develops more
in the second episode as well but the
cool thing about
loki is is that he's kind of an
antagonist himself
right he's not a hero he was or kind of
is a villain because this is the loki
who just tried to take over earth so you
have
loki who is a villain and then you have
another villain which adds a very
interesting dynamic that i actually
really enjoyed but again the mystery
isn't just
revolving around the antagonist this is
a whole
new world and a whole new force the tva
we are now dealing with time travel and
a sacred
timeline which they explain and it's all
very mysterious as to how everything is
going to work they do a great job of
explaining
who the tva is why the tva was formed
how it was formed in the very first
episode
and they explain it very well because
let's face it time travel sometimes is
very hard to get a grasp on
but it's executed well however there is
still a lot of mystery
as to what exactly this time travel that
we're going to see in the show
is going to effect if you caught a few
of my videos in the past where i talked
about the tva you know that the tva's
job is to basically
monitor different timelines in the
comics their job was making sure that
one timeline did not affect another if
one timeline started to affect another
they would go
and they would fix the problem and
sometimes even eliminate
a certain timeline so that's the force
that we're dealing with here they've
been around in the mcu for
essentially forever but now they have
loki in their headquarters and he's a
loose cannon and of course loki
is trying to get them to trust him but
can you ever really trust
loki the guy who stabs his own brother
and again it isn't the mature loki it's
the loki who just tried to take over
earth and
lost but the show really does make you
wonder what
exactly is going to happen in the show
and how is it going to affect the rest
of the mcu
because keep in mind the head writer
michael waldron is
also writing or i should say he already
wrote doctor strange in the multiverse
of madness with sam raimi so you have
one show that he wrote loki that has to
do with different timelines and time
travel
and then another one that he wrote that
has to do with the multiverse so to me
the big mystery is
what exactly is going to happen and how
is it going to blow up and send the
multiverse into madness
now my fourth reason as you might have
picked up on already is
although it is a very comedic show
it really does have some very grounded
serious parts to it and i think that's
very important because it's very easy to
make something just
laugh laugh laugh laugh laugh and not
have a very solid foundation or be very
grounded but
they did an excellent job at combining
the comedy with the mystery
with the seriousness and with a lot of
emotion which is something that you
might not really expect from loki
and i think that's why i enjoyed it so
much and last but not least
i really have to praise the actors on
this one and it's not just them doing a
good job on their own it's how they do
a good job with each other i've already
mentioned tom hiddleston and owen wilson
absolutely crush it tom hiddleston and
wunmi masaku
actually crush it as well like i
mentioned before but then you have owen
wilson
crushing it with gugu imbatara's
character who plays
judge rinslayer and i'm curious to what
people think but i personally think and
this is not a very obvious thing but i
think that there could be a little bit
of a romance there
it's not obvious or in your face i may
be picking up on something that's not
there but you'll all have to let me know
what you think after the first episode
comes out
but really the whole cast just
absolutely crushed it they killed it
with each other and on their own and
even some of the actors who aren't main
actors do an
incredibly good job overall i definitely
say
it's marvel's best disney plus show so
far and as a project
on its own from marvel it is one of the
better ones i've only seen two episodes
so i can't make a final judgment call on
where i would rank it but if it keeps at
this pace or gets any better than this
it's going to be pretty high up on my
list and it comes out in only a few
hours i'll be doing my live
watch party for the show like i've been
doing for the falcon and the winter
soldier in one division it'll start
tonight at 11
30 p.m pacific time and of course we'll
be talking about the show afterwards
and i hope everybody likes it i hope to
see everybody tomorrow during the live
stream
leave your final thoughts about loki in
the comments down below and let me know
how excited you are
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe with notifications turned on
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof
you